♪♪
IN THE MYTH
"LIFE RAFT PARACHUTE,"
BUSTER FOUND OUT HOW TERMINAL
VELOCITY CAN BE.
WE HAVE A WHOLE FOREARM
AND A HAND OVER HERE
ON THE RAFT, OVER.
BUT ON THE OPERATING TABLE,
ADAM AND GRANT RESURRECT BUSTER
FROM HIS FATAL FALL.
ROUND THREE.
[ BELL DINGS ]
AND WITH BUSTER
HAVING FAILED TO RIDE THE RAFT
LIKE INDIANA JONES,
JAMIE RIGS IT AS A PARACHUTE.
JUST GONNA GIVE A LITTLE EXTRA
AND LACE HIM A COUPLE OF PLACES.
I'M TIRED OF BUSTER
TAKING OFF ON ME.
HIS ASS IS HANGING OUT.
WOW. LOOK AT THAT.
IT'S GOT TO WORK THIS TIME.
[ LAUGHS ]
FAMOUS LAST WORDS.
TORY: Looking good so far,
Steve.
HE IS TAKING HIS TIME
SO HE DOESN'T RIP THE THING.
HE'S GONNA FAVOR THE UPWIND SIDE
OF THE "X" A LITTLE BIT, OVER.
YOU GUYS MAKE SURE
YOU CAN GET UNDER THAT TRUCK
IN A HURRY, OVER.
OKAY, STEVE, I'D SAY GO AHEAD
AND RELEASE AT WILL.
YOU LOOK GOOD, OVER.
OKAY, HE'S RELEASING, GUYS.
IT'S GOING.
OH, IT'S BEAUTIFUL!
BE CAREFUL BEFORE YOU
SPEAK TOO SOON.
LOOK AT THAT! WHOO!
IT'S NOT OVER YET.
I KNOW.
COME ON, BUSTER!
LOOK AT -- THOSE LITTLE ENTRY
RAMPS ARE LIKE WINGS, YOU KNOW?
OH, THAT'S GREAT!
[ CHUCKLES ]
Buster's on the ground.
WELL, THAT LOOKED LIKE
A MUCH NICER RIDE.
I'LL HAZARD A GUESS
THAT BUSTER MAY WELL BE
INTACT THIS TIME, ENTIRELY.
Narrator: BUT APPEARANCES
CAN BE DECEPTIVE.
BUSTER HAS ONCE AGAIN SUSTAINED
SOME SEVERE DAMAGE.
BUT WOULD HE HAVE SURVIVED?
ALL THE 50-G SHOCK WATCHES BROKE
ON ALL OF HIS LIMBS,
BUT IN HIS CHEST, THE 75
AND THE 100 DID NOT GET TRIPPED.
SO THAT MEANS THAT HE GOT
ALL BUSTED UP.
HE WOULD NOT BE A HAPPY CAMPER,
BUT HE MIGHT JUST BE ALIVE.
IF YOU COULD HAVE LEAPED OUT
OF THE AIRPLANE WITH THIS RAFT,
INFLATED IT IN MID-AIR,
RIGGED FOUR POINTS TO IT
SO YOU COULD HANG FROM IT
LIKE A PARACHUTE, YOU MIGHT...
JUST MIGHT SURVIVE.
BUT ALL THE OTHER ASPECTS
OF THIS ARE SO UNREALISTIC,
THE ODDS OF YOU BEING ABLE
TO ACHIEVE THIS RIG
WHILE FALLING OUT OF A PLANE
ARE SO UNLIKELY
AS TO BE ALMOST LUDICROUS.